I was 34 years old when I started
vaynermedia I had spent the 12 best
years of my youth building my dad's
liquor store for him I left that
business had no money had no equity I
was worthless to the bank vaynermedia
started in somebody else's conference
room because we had no money for rent so
it was a ton of Risk by normal standards
when somebody reads it on paper but not
necessarily for me it just felt like
progression I run vaynermedia we are an
800 person firm 100 million dollars in
revenue and four years from zero we work
with GE and Pepsi and Under Armor and
Toyota and the biggest brands in the
world what does a vaynermedia do we're a
modern day Mad Men we're a Madison
Avenue Agency the same people that used
to sell commercial time on anything you
ever did in radio and television we now
do that on Facebook Snapchat Instagram
and we produce the creative for the
brands to sell stuff through the phone